welcome to the seafar Massey talks La
conference Massey sifar
so my name is Natalie de rossier I'm the
principal of Massey college and it's my
great pleasure to welcome you here I
want to say that Massey college is built
on indigenous lands the lands of the
young wendat the Seneca and the
mississaugas of the credit I want to
acknowledge our duty of stewardship
toward this land which is the treaty
land of the mississaugas at the credit
and our great privilege to continue to
do and reflect on the future of vaccine
which is what we're going to discuss
today without further Ado we have lots
to discuss today so let me pass the
microphone to uh the president of cfar
Alan Bernstein one of Canada's foremost
scientist recipient of so many honors
and a great leader in Framing and
helping us cope with the the big
questions of our of our time Alan it's
such a pleasure to continue to do a
partnership between Massey and sifar and
thank you for your intellectual
leadership
thank you very much Nestle for that uh
very kind introduction and it's nice to
see you virtually
uh at this meeting uh good afternoon
everyone and welcome to the C4 Massey
talks uh cfar is very pleased uh yet
again to partner with Massey on this
annual series of conversations at the
Nexus of Science and Society it's
especially a pleasure for me to co-host
this year's event with Natalie who is
having so much impact she's in her third
year as the new principal I'll still say
new principal of Massey uh she's just
doing such a fabulous job we're at sort
of a mutual admiration Society here in
athlete this annual lecture series
started in 2015 and highlights not only
a distinguished senior scientist in this
case Derek Rossi you all say something
about in a moment but also some of the
amazing Junior fellows at Massey that
gives Massey the the energy that it has
previous lectures have spanned issues
such as the AI Revolution Unsolved
Mysteries of the Galaxy
and how social relationships affect our
health
all of our past talks are available on
cfar's YouTube channel and today's event
will also be posted there in about a
week
this afternoon stock could not be more
timely
mRNA vaccines as everybody knows have
played I think it's fair to say the
central role in the fight against covet
19. saving I think millions of lives
over the past year alone this technology
has the potential to revolutionize how
we treat other diseases including
diseases serious diseases like cancer
going forward
and we'll say more about that of course
in a moment first I'd like to also
introduce our moderator wencilung wenci
is uh a Massey journalism fellow she's a
toronto-based health reporter for the
Globe and Mail and is part of a team of
journalists currently covering the
covid-19 pandemic prior to joining the
globe she worked at the Prague post the
Vancouver son of Cambodia daily and
Thompson Road Reuters and joining me in
this discussion is Derek Rossi Derek is
a a Serial uh biotech entrepreneur
uh and a great stem cell scientist his
efforts in the development of
cutting-edge Technologies and novel
therapeutic strategies are at the very
Forefront of both regenerative medicine
and biotechnology
his development of
mRNA reprogramming was named by Time
Magazine as one of the top 10 medical
breakthroughs of 2010.
that same year Derek leveraged that
technology to found moderna a company
developing modified mRNA Therapeutics
and whose covid vaccine was being
deployed around the world
Derek and I share a special history as
he was one of my graduate students I
guess in the last century Derek uh so
welcome Wednesday and Derek I'd also
like to welcome our Massey Junior
fellows who will join our discussions
later on Nicholas bobrovitz savani
mascaran upasana Saha before we begin I
would like to take this opportunity to
again thank you College our partners in
this annual seafar Massey talk
seafar like Massey is a strong believer
in the power of diversity
interdisciplinary communities of inquiry
of excellence and of young people we
also believe in Sharing new knowledge
that we gain from science with everybody
the seafar Massey talks are a great
example of exactly the kind of
initiative that helps bring research to
a wide audience and to the Forefront now
to get this started I'll pass a virtual
microphone to UNC and I hope everybody
joins this hours talk Wednesday
thank you so much for that introduction
Ellen and thank you for having me here
today
um let's talk vaccines my first question
is for Derek um so as as Alan mentioned
you've been involved in the research
that led to the creation of mRNA uh
coveted vaccines for more than a decade
so I'm wondering pre-covered what were
you and other scientists trying to do
with and mRNA vaccine technology
well uh I will
um tell you what we were doing in the
lab and it was something totally
unrelated to vaccines or or for that
matter mRNA Therapeutics we were working
on a and this is often the way in
science you're working on something or
you think you're working on something
but in fact you're working on something
uh else so we were working on a problem
related to Stem Cell Biology
um and uh we decided to use uh mRNA as a
strategy to get to the end that we were
trying to get to in stem cell biology uh
and it totally didn't work it was a you
know a complete Nutter a disaster we
killed essentially all the cells in the
dish
uh and by the way I'll just say that
mRNA was discovered be the intermediate
between DNA and protein
protein synthesis proteins of the worker
base of the cells DNA contains the code
but mRNA is this necessary and obligate
intermediate molecule that was that
Discovery was made in in 1961. yet in
the intervening decades although uh many
tried many failed using mRNA to express
proteins of interest to to biologists
and similarly we followed in that path
so that could have been the end of the
story but uh we persevered we found a
workaround we we discovered some
forgotten work uh by some uh important
researchers at the University of
Pennsylvania uh Captain land kariko and
Drew Weissman who by the way will
predict will win the Nobel Prize but
their work had sort of been published
and was sort of forgotten about and we
found it uh and built upon it and
discovered through some you know
development that we could use this
molecule to express any protein we
desired both in the dish and then in
animals uh and that was what led me to
found moderna in 2010
right okay and and so how did how did
how did this kind of um
um how did how did it become um applied
to to covet 19.
well interestingly when I
um started the company the first uh the
first investor that I had was one of my
colleagues at Harvard a guy named Tim
Springer and the very first meeting we
had to talk about it we talked about
vaccines
um and uh we we talked about it
um mostly in the setting of a company
that was already trying to develop mRNA
vaccines a German company called curvac
and I so Tim said to me Derek what about
curebeck they're ready to do on vaccines
and I said yeah but it's not going to
work because they're not doing the right
modifications to the MRNA and sure
enough curvac recently had their covet
trial results come out and indeed it
didn't work so these modifications were
necessary so I got a little I took a
tangent though remind me what your
actual question was Lindsay I'm sorry oh
yeah yeah sorry so so the the groundwork
that you had with with this technology
with um RNA modification modified mRNA
technology like how how did that kind of
um where did that leap come from to to
apply that to oh vaccines thank you yeah
sorry it's two not enough cups of coffee
yet today
um so as I said we've talked about it in
2010 but and quite frankly I didn't want
to work on vaccines because it was a
therapeutic Paradigm for which there was
already really great Solutions I mean
vaccines have been in in the the human
involved in human health since 15th
century China in a very big well way
since the uh 18th century and there are
many ways to make vaccines that work
rather what I wanted to do was work on
developing medicines for which there was
no uh treatment at all and there's
literally thousands of genetic diseases
for which there isn't a an application
right now or a therapeutic strategy to
tackle so I really wanted to to tackle
uh genetic disease there's 6 000 genetic
diseases not including cancer
mRNA is a perfect solution for that so
when the company first started that is
what we were focused on
about five or six years in though we
turned attention to vaccines because
quite frankly it's um
it's got the lowest
um technical hurdle you could imagine
when you're bringing a new medicine to
patients a new therapeutic Paradigm you
shouldn't go after you know try to jump
over really really high hurdles you
should jump over the smallest hurdles
possible uh to you know demonstrate that
your uh technology works and is safe and
applicable to humans so vaccines present
a perfect opportunity for that so
honestly that is how moderna got into
the vaccine business as kind of a hey
this is an easy first application a
really Technic the technical hurdle
being the smallest
um and
then the pandemic hit of course they had
already developed multiple different
vaccines and run them through clinical
trials at the FDA and this was actually
part of the story that people don't know
it's not the first time that that mRNA
was applied to vaccines was uh SARS Cove
2 and coven 19. no there was trials run
on zika and rare and deadly forms of
influenza and settle the megalovirus and
others so that this experience was
gained uh that it was safe uh there was
a dose range that we knew would would
likely work and
um moreover that when you immunize
somebody against a pathogen they hadn't
seen before you could really uh robustly
stimulate the immune system to uh
generate antibodies and and and other
immune cells that would uh be uh yeah
the the foundation for a successful uh
vaccine
right okay so so you so you mentioned
these other these other types of
um viruses that that
um this type of Technology was was
um developed to to be applied to so so
beyond beyond um the Stars cov2 virus
like what what
um are mRNA vaccines and Therapeutics
are in the works right now like what's
what's in the pipeline okay well well
the the pipeline is uh huge and it's
getting larger by the day because
literally you know mRNA new mRNA
companies are springing up like
mushrooms around the planet uh and all
of large Pharma is going all in with
with mRNA so just for the companies that
that have been in it for a while for
example modern and you know biontech and
even curavac uh you know there's there's
vac I I would argue that the entire
vaccine industry is going to be mRNA
based uh within five years
you know influenza a yearly influence of
vaccine is coming you know zika a
vaccine HIV uh Epstein-Barr virus
NEPA virus and we really hope that Nipa
doesn't really jump into humans because
it's really deadly so the the list of uh
clinical programs that are already in
the clinic and or close to the clinic is
long for vaccines uh it's equally long
for Therapeutics
um you know the when you have the
ability to use mRNA to express a protein
proteins are set involved in essentially
every aspect of our biology and every
aspect of our pathophysiology and the
setting of disease so there's so many
you know the one of the challenges we
had with modern in the early days is
what to work on first because we could
work on literally thousands of
applications so I'm really excited by
the fact that that you know this massive
Global Spotlight has been shown on this
technology it's proven itself to be
really robust uh and
um
now there's this massive uh influx of of
resource uh mobilized both people brain
brain power and uh uh Financial resource
so I I really see that you know that
the future uh for mRNA vaccines is clear
I think the whole industry is going
vaccines but I would say mRNA
Therapeutics are pretty close to uh
being a reality as well so we will see
that over the next
a few years uh and decades to come right
on this issue of the the international
scientific collaboration like
um
Ellen maybe you can talk about
what has that that role the role been in
terms of the international collaboration
in creating
um in creating mRNA vaccines so quickly
for covet 19.
well you know it's interesting
um the the sequence of the virus was was
first developed by scientists in China
in late December early January 2020 and
they put that sequence on the web
and it was moderna who I think first uh
captured that sequence off the web it
was public but got that sequence off the
web and within about four or five days
it really developed a vaccine that we're
all using now anybody's got the modern
vaccine was the one that was made four
or five days after uh back in January
January 2020. uh so that that the whole
scientific effort really turned on
global scientific collaboration starting
with I think a really an amazing uh
gesture by scientists in China
um so we shouldn't forget that that was
absolutely key and of course the the
modern vaccine took another nine months
to actually test in humans to make sure
it was safe and effective but but the
the actual vaccine was made within days
and and that's the power of the MRNA
vaccines is that they're a plug-and-play
kind of thing you can
just make it synthetically in the lab
you don't have to grow anything in cells
like you do with the viral Vector
vaccines you don't have all the protein
production challenges you have with
protein subunitive vaccines that the big
companies like sanofi and now novovax
are having with a protein subunits
against covet so that Global
collaboration has been key I think the
other aspect of all this of course is
the the scientific Community globally
has been sharing information quickly and
openly for the last almost two years now
around this fact around this pandemic
both vaccine development but also the
epidemiology the modeling all aspects of
drug development all aspects of this so
it's been I think one of the great
lessons
um for the world and certainly for the
scientific Community but and for our
political leaders has been how important
this Global collaboration is because the
end of the day this is not a Canadian
problem or an American problem it's a
global problem and so uh you know if we
don't if we don't address this pandemic
everywhere
we're not haven't dealt with the
pandemic so we need to be working
together on this uh both from the
scientific point of view the the
politics point of view making vaccines
delivering vaccines around the world
etc etc etc and I think so that that
initial Act of sharing that information
the sequence information of the virus uh
really is what the whole thing is turned
on I mean I think the other thing is
you know unlike every previous pandemic
that's happened on this planet including
the SARS one which didn't turn into a
pandemic luckily because it's a very
lethal virus it's sort of burned itself
out pretty quickly but um we've had this
is a pandemic characterized by science
if you think about the molecular
surveillance to detect all these
variants
and the PCR reaction
to see who's got the virus and now the
MRNA vaccines of course this is all new
technology that was not available back
in 2002 we couldn't have done any of
this in 2002. this was very you know
sequencing was around but it was very
primitive so all of this comes out of
global scientific collaboration
um that won a number of Nobel prizes
Derek mentioned maybe a Nobel Prize in
the future near future hopefully for the
group in Philadelphia perhaps other
people but the
um the PCR reaction that is enough was
one Nobel Prize as did uh DNA sequencing
so I think we're really seeing uh a
scientifically driven control of these
pathogens based on global collaboration
it's really quite remarkable yeah I'll
just I'll just jump in to add one more
thing to say that luckily it was science
that was the industry that was relied
upon to to to meet this challenge
because science actually knows no
borders that's the way science works we
we you know scientists are you know very
you know we publish our work in
international journals we collaborate
internationally is what science does so
science knows no borders so luckily it
fell to science to uh you know meet this
challenge had it you know fell to I
don't know some other industry you know
maybe the let's say the political
political class if they you know imagine
that somehow they could have solved this
problem that would have been a bigger
problem because that sort of global
collaboration isn't set up so I think if
science was poised and but Alan's right
you know many things needed to be uh uh
discovered and at the ready to to
respond so quickly and and so the timing
was right in terms of the Technologies
but certainly science responded as
science does I think so I think it's a
great moment for science quite frankly
okay let me get back to the the global
uh efforts in in a moment but
um I wanted to to ask Derek
um in terms of of
um these other other types of
applications for the MRNA vaccines how
how do MRI vaccines work for say cancer
compared to SARS cov2
yeah so
um so actually there's there's three
sort of lines that one can approach with
with cancer vaccines so the first is
that many cancers
um uh Express
um New Found Pro new proteins that are
specific to cancer cells they're called
neoantigens so cancers tend to be very
mutagenic it's but it's a large part of
driving cancer as a mutagenic phenotype
with new uh combinations of proteins
translocations and point mutations
arising so these are called neoantogens
so
um you could imagine targeting uh making
a vaccine against Neo common neoantigens
so for example a really good example of
that is a gene called k-ras so k-ras is
involved in you know more than 25
percent of all human Cancers and very
specific mutations happen in the k-ros
gene so it drives you know 40 percent of
colorectal cancels cancers 85 percent of
pancreatic cancers 30 percent of lung
cancers it's a lot of cancer so uh k-ras
with these particular mutations you can
immunize somebody prior to so it'd be a
prophylactic vaccine such that
should their body generate a k-ras
mutation they might already have
protection in place and their clinical
programs are ongoing for that
another way that you could imagine a
cancer vaccine is um
somebody already has cancer and you
could sequence their neoantigens again
using you know really pretty much
everybody that gets cancer in a and
visits a major hospital has their their
tumors sequenced so you know what's the
underlying molecular drivers and what
you know antigens are present and so you
could actually develop and mRNA is so
fast again Allen mentioned it a little
while ago you could very quickly
generate you know mrnas for neoantigens
for somebody who's come in and is
presenting a tumor so that would be a
sort of a very personalized cancer
vaccine and these uh studies are also in
the clinic and ongoing and then the
final area I think because I think
cancer is really the frontier that we're
gonna next really see a Major Impact
from the MRNA technology and the one
that I particularly like is intratumoral
delivery of mrnas so you you know you
can scan somebody's body you can see
where their tumors are and most of the
time you can get some sort of a needle
in there uh into the tumor generally
speaking uh and you could now have the
tumor deliver some mRNA to express uh uh
proteins that for example call in the
immune system you know bring in the
immune system so you know there's
programs for il-12 for example is in a
phase two at moderna again it's this
cytokine that that
um
regulates a couple of immune cells
natural killer cells inside of toxic T
cells and you know you're putting this
right into the center and by the way
tumors normally have very good
mechanisms for shutting out immune
infiltration so this is a way to combat
that and I I'm really encouraged by that
approach so there's there's multiple
different ways to approach cancer with
with mRNA and I really think I would I
would predict that next to vaccines uh
application and tumors will will be
um and tumor biology will be a big
Frontier and we'll see some great
successes in that forthcoming but that
is a forward-looking statement by the
way okay wow well um Ellen I know for
for you HIV is a particular interest how
um how how how might scientists approach
creating an mRNA vaccine for something
as complicated as HIV well again you
know it's um it's as Derek was talking
about his early days in this area
science does not go in a straight line
so one of the Pioneers in this area that
made the vaccines possible that the the
the covid-19 vaccines the guy called
Barney Graham
and Barney was working on a number of
different viruses including HIV and
discovered that if you wanted to take
that the equivalent of the spike protein
for HIV you needed to sort of lock it
into a certain shape so that the body
would the immune system in your body
would actually see it make an immune
response so he and a postdoc figured out
how to do that for other viruses
and that's been applied now to covet
so uh as Dirk's been saying for all
these other viruses and for therapeutic
vaccines
now of course we're thinking about
making vaccines against HIV the
challenge with HIV is that the variants
that we're so worried about with covid
which come up you know once every three
or four months there's a new variant
with HIV it's you know one a day it's a
very mutable virus and so new viruses
are coming up all the time so the one
issue would be is it possible just as
Derek was talking about with a
personalized vaccine development for
cancer could you make personalized
vaccines for a particular variant of HIV
that predominates in a region and then
make a different one every time it
changes so you're always one step ahead
hopefully of where HIV is going and so
you're constantly re-synthesizing this
plug-and-play technology to kind of
catch up with the virus or hopefully be
one step ahead of it so that that's
there's a lot of work going on in that
area with the MRNA vaccine technology so
um I I think that that this is very this
technology is perfectly applicable to
this to HIV and to other situations
where you really got to keep
re-engineering the vaccine
um and we should remember that Delta is
about the fourth or fifth generation of
variants yet the vaccine that is so
effective against Delta
was actually the original vaccine that
was made against the Wuhan strain that
came out of Wuhan in the first place I I
was asked the other day by a reporter
what happens if that no That vaccine no
longer works what happens if they're the
new variant well it'd be so easy to
re-engineer
uh the vaccine to deal with that new
variant
indeed I'm sure modern and I'm sure
Pfizer et cetera I've done all that and
well I know they have so
um uh that's what we have to do with
with HIV
the other thing I would say Wednesday is
we shouldn't forget that we're still in
sort of the Model T stage of mRNA
technology
this is early early days if you look at
other scientific Technologies whether
it's DNA sequencing PCR reaction you
name it they change so quickly so to
take DNA sequencing which every lab is
doing as Derek said if you have cancer
and we're sequencing all these viruses
now the covid-19 doing genomic
surveillance to actually detect the
Delta variance in our populations
the cost of doing that sequencing and
the efficiency of doing it has gone down
over 10 million fold over about 20 years
that's because they're whole new
technologies so I think we can safely
predict that the MRNA vaccine mRNA
vaccine technology is not going to stay
the same it's going to get better uh and
we're going to go from model T's to
Chevys to BMWs pretty quickly
um and and maybe testless so uh you know
I think I think it's going to be that'll
open up because technology is always
rate limiting that's going to open up
whole new applications that are truly
the impossible at the moment
I remember doing some of the uh early uh
Model T version DNA sequencing in your
lab back in the 1980s uh and it was you
know labor intensive and slow and and so
exactly to your point
um but but it's a good Southern blocks
when you're in the lab a lot I I did a
lot of Southern plots indeed uh so
um but I think you're exactly right
actually you know we're it's in its
infancy now and and as I said you know
now there's so much money and resource
uh and people being uh mobilized to work
on Mr you know next-gen mRNA technology
and and applications that can only do
exactly as you said which is you know
lead to innovation in this space so
that's going to happen it's a really
it's an important point
so I guess like on on the road to
getting there to that that BMW stage
what sort of um what sort of drawbacks
or or think cautions do you think
we need to take well so the the biggest
thing
um and I've said this for a really long
time is delivery delivery delivery so
mRNA is a macromolecule it's very very
large
um if
relative to you know a small molecule
like an aspirin or something like that
which is Tiny by comparison
um so get it and and it can't do
anything unless it gets through the cell
membrane into the cytoplasm and goes to
the ribosome which is the protein
production organelle and you know to
have its code red to turn into a a a a
protein so delivery I've been saying it
was always going to be the challenge
well this is where you know lipid
nanoparticles have met the challenge
already uh partially for this so
everybody's heard of the banana
particles now they're these little sort
of fat droplets that do two things they
protect the you know they protect the
MRNA uh in this you know inner sphere
going into the into the body which by
the way we express a lot of molecules
whose job is to specifically degrade RNA
rnases so it protects but it also
facilitates uptake into cells uh and
allowing the MRNA to be delivered uh and
lipid nanoparticle Technologies
development
that was a Canadian development by the
way absolutely yeah yeah it's got a long
long history and and it's it's and each
generation of lipid nanoparticles is
getting better and better and better and
less and less sort of you know have side
effects because early Generations had
side effects and were quite toxic uh I
think the thing that that I'm really
looking forward to and I know it's
happening already uh in another company
I founded intelia Therapeutics one of
these crispr companies uh is decorating
the LNP with sort of address tags
to send it to particular cell types and
tissue types uh because you know when
we're injecting into our arm here it's a
non-specific
um delivery it's just going into our
arms so it's getting into our muscle our
dendritic resident dendritic cells and
Resident immune cells but that's you
know pretty relatively non-specific I
think it's going to get really exciting
when we can put mRNA into an LMP or
another type of delivery vehicle put a
very specific address tag on it and get
it to go right to a particular cell type
or tissue type in the body I think
that's that's so I would argue that
that's still a limitation I think your
question was what are the what are the
limitations right now that's certainly a
limitation it's also a little you know
big limitation honestly with this
current pandemic is manufacturing I mean
you know there was not uh the capacity
the manufacturing infrastructure to
produce many billions of doses you know
in the few weeks that we wish that we
could have produced many billions of
doses to deploy around the world so uh
that is also changing I mean moderna had
a GMP grade manufacturing facility built
already very boldly in 2018 it's about
20 minutes north of me here in Norwood
Mass but now uh facilities are are
popping up around the planet again so it
Canada has uh is on board with doing a
an mRNA facility Africa both Pfizer and
modern are going to Africa which I think
is amazing it'll be all around the
planet so I think one of the uh the next
time and there will be a next time that
a pandemic comes and this technology is
able to address it we'll be able to do
it on an even faster timeline because of
this manufacturing bottleneck which we
have found ourselves in this past year
so Wednesday I would say when dare said
delivery I was going to agree with him
he went a different direction with the
word delivery and
um I I think
you know it's one thing to make vaccines
but you have to vaccinate people and so
you have to deliver them uh into those
arms uh and that involves manufacturing
as Derek said it'll also involves uh
dollars because you have to need the
money to actually make these things
um and so going back to your question
about global collaboration against where
uh wealthy countries have a long way to
go to really provide the resources
financial resources and and
Manufacturing resources
for Africa for the developing world and
for those countries everywhere that
can't afford to do it because if we've
learned from Delta if nothing else if
the virus is anywhere it's everywhere it
you know if we're fooling ourselves that
we think if we get rid of the virus you
know here in Ontario we've eliminated
the pandemic we know that's not true
it's just we have proof of that the
Delta moved from India to Ontario and in
about a week SARS one moved from Hong
Kong to Canada in about three days we
all travel around the world you know et
cetera et cetera so delivery is a key
issue and and of course vaccine
hesitancy is another one because again
you have to get the vaccine into arms
it's not enough to do the science
manufacture it and distribute it and pay
the money you need to get people to to
line up and get in their arms and I
think that requires a lot of political
leadership I think we saw that very
clearly throughout this pandemic in
different countries and it requires
dealing with dismissive information
issue uh that's so Rife on the web uh
and all of us you know have got friends
relatives who but I heard that the
vaccines uh you know prevent you from
getting pregnant I want to get pregnant
well you know they see they'll say one
crazy message so it really those are
major issues which I never would have
predicted but have turned out to be
major issues in terms of actually
dealing with a pandemic and now
the only people really who are getting
serious disease from covet in North
America are people who are not fully
vaccinated
and it's a shame you know they're
getting really seriously ill or dying or
getting long coveted and and nobody you
know you don't want that because they're
really getting full of misinformation
and of course people in Africa are not
even getting that opportunity to get
vaccinated so I think delivery is a big
issue
so in in terms of this misinformation
and vaccine hesitate to see what what do
you think needs to happen to
um you know in terms of of all these
other applications for mRNA Technologies
what needs to happen to to sort of
um get the get the public on on board
with with no actually accepting it well
well it you know starts education I mean
honestly it's it's interesting when when
the pandemic first hit and you know mRNA
was mentioned in the press as a
potential application it's it amazed me
I guess that you know people didn't
actually know what mRNA was you know the
the average person in a town people have
heard of DNA they know it contains the
code people have heard of proteins
although they mostly think it's
something that they eat with their steak
or in their but they're the you know the
the real uh worker bees but people
hadn't known about mRNA so I spent about
last year and a half two years basically
giving Every Woman webinar I possibly
could anybody that asked sort of
educating about what mRNA is and what
vaccines are we've seen a lot of that so
so education is really really the way
um you know people have to realize that
scientists are actually the most
skeptical people on planet Earth uh when
when scientists make a discovery uh
there's nobody who wants to challenge
that Discovery more than the person
who's made the discovery so you make a
discovery in science and then you spend
two years throwing rocks at your own
Discovery doing everything possible to
to show that somehow you've
misinterpreted the result or so Derek
let me let me jump in here
I gave the very first Massey seafar talk
and it was about the scientific process
and its title was doubt everything yeah
well exactly throw rocks you know
scientists throw rocks at their own data
and by the way their peers sure do that
when they when they go to publish their
peer-reviewed papers so uh
Facebook is not the domain of Science
and the internet is not the domain of
Science and I I say it all the time and
I say it now I take the opportunity the
internet is a liar there's a lot of
great stuff out on the internet but
there's a lot of nonsense and certainly
social media there's probably more
nonsense than great stuff so we have to
educate the public that that really the
domain of science is
in scientific journals and that science
is real and that science is not in
collusion with governments to uh you
know enact you you can't believe some of
the emails I get from people I mean just
they they're they they Boggle my mind
um so it's a big deal and some countries
and some governments do it better than
others so for example I was just in
Spain the end of last week beginning of
uh over the weekend uh in a town called
Oviedo in the north of Spain where you
know myself along with a few of the
other really key people involved in the
vaccine were being celebrated by an
award ceremony and the entire town 250
000 people was engaged and
you know they've been doing research
they had the the children doing uh I saw
uh they had a project 2 000 school kids
did pictures on what the job of the
scientist is and what we had been doing
to develop this vaccine you know so it
engages the school-age kill uh children
then we had a forum with high school
kids we had an open public discourse and
when you actually talk to scientists
real scientists uh you find out oh what
do you know they're they're they're real
people they're not inclusion they seem
to be passionate about what they do and
my goodness they're pretty darn
skeptical in the end so you know science
is real and uh We've it's it's I I was
shocked at how science could become sort
of a political lever particularly I live
in the U.S
I'm Canadian but I live in the U.S uh
and it's shocked me how that how how
that has happened here maybe it
shouldn't be shocking but uh it's it's
problem it's a real problem and and we
need to educate educate from the ground
up small children all the way through
that science is real
right okay
[Music]
um
one one just last question and we'll
make it quick before I introduce start
introducing the messy fellows but
um I wondered you know on the on the
subject of delivery and and and and and
with with the idea of a global
collaboration in in making these these
Technologies what are your thoughts on
sharing those Health the the recipes for
those Technologies to to be so that
people around the world can access them
well well that's a good question
um so I would argue that
um
it and I agree with Alan I mean we have
to vaccinate the planet that that's
that's clear the the the the
bottleneck is not that the recipe isn't
shared with around the planet the
bottleneck is manufacturing and the
expertise get nine year prep so that's
the bottleneck
um and I would argue that intellectual
property is really really important for
the science for science to continue to
innovate and continue to develop uh key
medicines if you take away inter
um uh intellectual property protection
you are going to have less private
sector investment uh in in technologies
that one day could deliver the answer so
I think I think I'll jump in here and
then I think we should move on but I
think you can you can square the circle
in other words I think in this in the
case of a global pandemic I think it is
possible to respect you know
intellectual property rights and issues
while sharing the formula as it were and
actually assisting with their production
During the period of a pandemic so that
there's there's a the eyepiece protected
but we also protect the world because
the end of the day it's maybe not in the
case of but well moderna used public
funds as well but there was public funds
considerable public funds used to
develop these vaccines so I think we
need to kind of figure out a way to both
respect IP as well as share the formula
and get it I would agree with that so I
didn't I didn't mean to suggest
otherwise just to say though that IP is
such an important uh pillar of
biotechnology and Innovation so you
really can't just you just can't get rid
of it because you're going to have a
much bigger problem in the future if you
do that so I agree there's there's a way
to square the circle and do both but
that's not the challenge here the
challenge is manufacturing the moment is
manufacturing yeah I agree manufacturing
we should move on to hear all these
great yes let me uh let me give the the
fellows a chance to ask some questions
um so let me first introduce uh Nicholas
brobovitz uh he is an MD non-resident
Junior fellow and he Nick is a medical
student and health researcher with
interests in emergency medicine public
health and research methods and he's the
research lead at zero tracker which is a
public website that tracks and analyzes
covid-19 prevalence globally
um and we also have
um sivani bahiskarin
Savannah is a PhD candidate in
environmental chemistry at the
University of Toronto and in addition to
her science work she is also deeply
interested in science policy and
evidence informed decision making so in
2018
um Savannah co-founded the Toronto
Science policy Network and among the
national campaigns she has co-led is the
report on the early impacts of covid-19
on graduate students across Canada
and we also have Sana Saha she is in a
fourth year PhD candidate in health
economics at U of T and ufasana is also
a director of Integrated Health Systems
and Partnerships at Humber River
Hospital and she has led the rollout
um led the rollout of vaccine clinics
around the city of Toronto including
helping launch at U of T St George
campuses vaccine clinic
um let me uh let me uh ask uh upasana
first
um go ahead and sign if you have
questions and I invite the other Junior
fellows to to ask questions as as
follows
thanks Quincy and and thank you Alan and
Derek
um one of the questions because we've
heard a lot about Canada addressing the
manufacturing bottleneck um and then
also advancing about the next
applications of the modified mRNA what
are one or two the really important
things that universities and
organizations like sci-fi can do right
now to be better better prepared for a
future circumstance for a pandemic if it
was to occur
well I'll jump in here there so I I
think the the job of universities and
you can see that in the vaccines that uh
we're all using now for covid uh is to
do the fundamental science
uh because that's what they really do
well so the you know the MRNA technology
as Derek said came out of the University
of Pennsylvania uh uh Derek polished it
as it were at Harvard and then the
company
um uh it's the Oxford AstraZeneca
vaccine uh and the viral Vector of act
technology was actually developed at
McMaster University way back by Frank
Graham so I think what universities
could contribute to this pipeline
um is the fundamental research
um uh and I think what what cifar does I
think really well is uh to do research
in any Talent you need people like Derek
uh and and we're pretty good at
nurturing great talent and mentoring
great young people uh and so and and uh
so I think that's that's our role but
but uh generally but I think the role of
universities it's critical
um and it doesn't stop by the way to the
vaccines if you think about the PCR
reaction well that was developed at a
company has seen this but but uh DNA
sequencing was developed in an academic
environment but by Fred Sanger at the
Sanger Center so at Cambridge University
so those Technologies which are so key
to dealing with this virus were all
developed if he's traced them back
uh academic environment so I think
that's a big role critical role and only
universities can do that because if you
think about as Derek said the companies
are now piling into RNA vaccine
technology
but the big companies wouldn't have done
that five years ago
uh it was too risky too long term so
only universities can nurture that high
risk uh long-term research uh that may
or may not pay off in terms of a product
uh now universities are lousy at making
product in my judgment that's where
companies come in that's where biotech
companies come in that's where a big
Pharma comes in so there's a real
complementarity between the private
sector and the public sector in terms of
you know universities
um and when it works it works
fantastically well as we're seeing with
the RNA vaccines
um yeah I would yeah I would agree
universities are the the largest and
most productive Innovation ecosystems on
the planet and so University leadership
should continue to Foster just that so
couldn't agree more with what Allen said
bunny can you do uh would you would you
like to uh follow up
yes I actually had a question regarding
how how what challenges did you face
moving from studying mRNA in a
university setting into developing
moderna and moving that into an
industrial environment and what
challenges may be that you're
anticipating that were didn't end up
being challenges at all so if you can
speak a little bit about well well I was
a first-time entrepreneur when I uh did
uh founded moderna and um I was lucky in
that I did my research in you know at uh
at Harvard University and I was in the
ecosystem of uh Cambridge uh Boston
which is the largest ecosystem of
Biotech on planet Earth so I got lucky
that I I did my work in the center of
this biotech uh the the biotech
Hub of the planet uh so that allowed me
actually relatively easy access to
mentors that had done it before which is
really important as I said what first
investor was Tim Springer who had
founded Millennium uh uh well
um leukocyte that was bought by
Millennium Pharmaceuticals he was in my
department I've had many people in my
department that had founded companies so
great mentors uh and you know also
within that ecosystem there's a uh you
know IP expertise
um Venture Capital big Pharma is there
so it really is a neat the ecosystem is
totally set up there to to and you know
it's something that I don't know how
many what the number of companies had
come out of Harvard and MIT each year is
but it's astounding I can tell you that
so they've got it down to an art there
that's for sure and they have it as such
in other places of the planet too and I
talked to Canadian universities uh a lot
about this I've talked to U of T and and
you Alberta and others about what they
need to do or what more they could do
and this ecosystem is built over a long
period of time but it it you know it and
it usually needs you know an anchor sort
of an early anchor company history you
know some company that strikes it big
and then builds the ecosystem builds
from there you know for example in South
San Francisco it was Genentech uh and lo
and behold you know 40 years after after
the founding of Genentech there's this
vibrant ecosystem all around the South
Side actually to be honest it starts
with great academic institutions back to
this point that that Alan make because
that's that's really the key it starts
from that but then you need an anchor
company and then all of these other
pieces so
um did uh did I what did what was I
anticipating and not anticipating I
actually didn't know and I used to I
ended up teaching a course to Harvard
undergrads about sort of after I did
modern and a couple of other companies
about how to sort of translate one's
ideas into sort of out of the bench to
the bend side by the formation of
Biotech and I always started the lecture
every year by uh telling my students
that when I first started on this
journey I knew less than a block of wood
knows about you know launching a biotech
company because until you've actually
had that experience and did that because
it's totally different different than uh
you know academic science you know we're
great at science but we're not so good
at moving those ideas towards patients
which of course involves you know
raising money yeah we raise money with
grants but not not in the same way that
you raise money to start and and
continue can have your biotech thrive
so there's lots to be learned from the
um from doing it but there's also lots
to be learned for mentors so every young
person I talk to and it's all the time
you know that's really the key thing get
somebody who's done it first early that
can give you advice to help you
along the way
uh Nick do you have a question for the
panel I do yeah thanks so much for the
great conversation so far
um I have a question just to follow up
on something you guys mentioned earlier
you talked about how easy it is to
modify mRNA vaccines to new variants
which is great
um but you know at the population level
as you mentioned manufacturing and
rolling out vaccines can be quite a
cumbersome task uh if kovid continues to
mutate at what point does it make sense
to modify the vaccines like is there a
consensus on when that might be do you
have like a personal opinion on the
threshold of Effectiveness
um yeah yeah sure well just to tell you
that so so Alan I'll let you uh in in
one sec just to say that uh beta uh beta
and Delta very mRNA variants already in
phase two at moderna so uh when you and
the reason beta and beta emerged in
South Africa the reason that it was
chosen to go through and be a Gen 2
vaccine if you were is because studies
had shown that gen 1 vaccine while
being protective still against beta were
not as good at neutralizing the anybody
or the uh viruses ability to infect
cells there was a market drop off uh in
protective ability so it made sense to
you know again the sequencing was done
between who exactly where the mutations
were you can very easily tailor an mRNA
for that and and that's as I said in
phase two similarly Delta so I think the
the threshold really is when Gen 1 or 2
or 3 vaccines cease to become you know
protective you know really protective
and you see more and more breakthrough
infection infections and that's
measurable and we know who's been
vaccinated yet still ends up with covet
or ends up you know hopefully not in the
hospital or on ventilators or dying but
that happens at a certain uh frequency
as well so this is the most studied
medical intervention in all of human
history that's for sure so
uh essentially every academic and you
know Pharma research around the planet
has got some doing something working on
covet so this is this is going to really
help in our response but but covet is uh
or SARS Cove 2 is Def almost certainly
going to become endemic we're going to
see it you know every year kind of like
influenza I think it's mostly
epidemiologists agree it will continue
to mutate hopefully it doesn't become
much more deadly and if it becomes real
deadly usually they you know viruses
burn themselves out like the original
SARS or Ebola or something like this
usually it's not it's not really in the
in the interests of the uh of the virus
to get to become too deadly and kill its
host of course
um but we're gonna we're gonna be
dealing with it for a long time Alan did
you want to add something no well I
would agree with what you said I would
just add quickly Nicholas to answer your
question uh two things one is I think
that's where the other Technologies come
in so if you see from the epidemiology
that the incidence of covet is starting
to go up
and couple that with sequencing and you
see that a new variant frequency is
starting to go up
uh even in people who have been
vaccinated you already have a clue
before you do any lab work
that the vaccine is not working against
this new variant you can then you know
take a serum from those individuals and
see their if their antibodies actually
neutralize the virus
to confirm that so uh if you see that
then you have to then go from there so I
think that's it's at that point that you
to go back to your question which is a
great question it's the kind of question
of the day really it's at that point
that you think we need a new vaccine so
um now in terms of viral Evolution uh as
as Derek was saying you know the
selection pressure on the virus in the
first instance is to be more
transmissible
and the the Delta is is about four to
six-fold more transmissible than the
original virus
uh and obviously the more quickly you
can spread without killing the host the
more selective Advantage you have now as
more and more people get vaccinated we
may or may not see immune Escape
variants that is variants that are no
longer uh subject to the vaccine and the
antibodies or other immune system
responses that are elicited by those
vaccines
now if that happens then you know we've
got to make a new vaccine we haven't
seen that yet I mean there are some
vaccines some viruses sorry some
variants that are a little bit more
resistant to the to the vaccine than
than before but but nothing striking so
it is possible
the constraints on the virus to mutate
and still be viable are such that it
can't escape even the original
generation of vaccines that's a
possibility and I think the longer this
goes on and the more and more people get
vaccinated and the longer time goes
before we actually see a an escape
variant the more confident we'll be able
to feel gee this this bar can't escape
this vaccine no that's that's a hope
that's my fingers are crossed okay so
we'll see what happens
um but I think we can kind of rest
assured and maybe uh it's too confident
that because of the Plug and Play and
how quickly we can develop these
vaccines we can re-engineer them uh to
do to do to deal with any new variant of
concern that comes up well
exactly right and I would just add that
it really shows you know how you know
thank you virologist for teaching us
about how coronaviruses get into cells
because basically the spike protein is
that that uh protein that engages the
ace2 receptor to initiate the Infectious
cycle uh and it's interaction with the
ace2 receptor on human cells it's a
structural interaction so you're not
going to be able to mutate that Spike
protein so much and still imagine that
it that engages with the human cell so
the target is exactly right to block the
initiation of the Infectious cycle I
think where we might have to worry about
a little bit is when other genes with it
and of course the whole genome is
mutating of the coronavirus when other
genes mutate to
um you know propagate uh viral
replication and hopefully not uh
lethality that don't act through the
spike protein because the spike protein
clearly is the right Target and we've
targeted very effectively with current
vaccines and there's a selective
pressure to have that that interaction
between the spike protein and the ace2
receptor remain intact so I agree with
that think about a lock and a key
Nicholas that you know the the AC
receptor is the lock and the spike
protein is the key the lock isn't
changing we don't mutate so if you
mutate the key too much it doesn't work
anymore in that lock exactly right so
but if the other proteins in the virus
start to mutate then we have to rely on
drugs probably and there are some drugs
now being developed they're therapeutic
they're not they're not they're not
preventative they're therapeutic but
I've seen Napoli's back on the screen so
that's that signs that that we're going
to have to lock and key this this
discussion uh in in some fashion I mean
what a fabulous discussion how much
we've learned and I know I think it
demonstrate the the value of the C4
talks the massive C4 talks because we
wanted to continue to talk to you and
listen to you I mean this demonstrate
the power science the power of
interdisciplinarity all of you have
spoken to the big challenges for all
disciplines uh including laws uh in
terms of of moving to a better future a
future where we're all healthier and are
able to resist uh the future pandemics
so on current thank you so much uh all
of you thank you to the junior fellows
thank you to wincy for leading the
discussion and thank you to our both of
our panelists Alan Bernstein and thank
you very much Derek for making yourself
available for this this talk uh you have
a standing invitation to come to Massey
College anytime
thank you thank you all
[Music]